welcome to the Dean show I'm with
Mohammed bit out Salaam alaikum peace be
with you
how are you brother hand of them great
how you been good good it's good to
finally meet yes it's big man I love the
show and I love watching it so it's good
fun of the year Muhammad Bilal I'm very
I'm very I mean and you know it didn't
go many people are becoming nervous in
the climate so some people they would
have been changed to Moe Bailey but not
with Muhammad Bilal unrecognizably
someone who's you know proud to be
Muslim named after one of the greatest V
greatest men to ever walk the earth
Prophet Muhammad peace and mercy be upon
and Bilal we know velocity longline yeah
and you got the name beautiful mashallah
yeah pastor I'm did a lot from you
originally from your born in the States
yeah born in Chicago or in Chicago yeah
yeah so you're also now UFC fighter yes
I've been in UFC now for three years
three years yeah sometime how's that
going good hander that I'm on a three
fight winning streak got another one
coming up June 1st so it'd be fun ok
we're gonna get into we're gonna have
some fun ok I'm gonna get I'm gonna get
your reaction to - you know the whole
Boston Citadel yeah ok I heard something
and I want take off from here and it all
connects we'll connect it all so we're
gonna go we're gonna hear this from you
you know Matt Serra a former UFC
champion yeah yeah he has that show and
he has he had one of his guests I forgot
what his name is
let's listen to this clip and then okay
let me now go into my question how's it
yep you just came up with that that word
terrorist he's lucky to get charged with
the terrorist act cuz he came from
another country came here with 20 guys
to start trouble and attack khabib so
he's lucky to get charged with that okay
so I want you to imagine this muhammad
Bulow he's coming over from Palestine
right he's got 30 brothers with him
he's on see your American citizen right
I wouldn't do something like that
obviously but just paint the picture now
right because we call out a lot of the
double standards out there you know some
of the open you know hypocrisy that's
around there so I'm just I'm just
envisioning okay in your head you got
Muhammad Billa he's on a work work work
visa right because kind of McGregor he's
coming from
he's on a work visa right yeah I didn't
mention it but this just had my scoop my
my I was thinking but I heard I don't
know who the co-host is from the who's
that speaking the guy who's is Aaron uh
what's his name
I know you talked you know talked about
he's an actor famous actor right yeah
okay so he said it he said men he's
lucky hitting a charged with terrorism
what do you think would happen to you or
any Muslim vite vite anyway yeah they're
definitely getting arrested we're going
to jail for a while and uh I think we're
getting kicked out of the UFC it's going
to be in the papers as a terrorist and
it's gonna the headlines gonna read
Mohammed that's gonna be like the first
one Mohammed terrorist attacks bus
guaranteed hundred percent so I mean
like you said it's a double standard
he's kind of regret and uh right now
he's like the face of the organization
so like the UFC's it not gonna punish
him like they would it like any other
UFC fighter they would have been cut
right away hundred percent but it's kind
of aggregor i know he brings in the
money but doing something like that like
you have little kids looking up some
kids watching him and then they see him
do something like that so they're gonna
think the same thing that they could do
something like that if they wanted to or
they could go to school and hurt
somebody or throw stuff at windows break
one knows that nothing i happened to him
just cuz they're looking at their idol
kind of a Gregor and nothing's happening
to them and he's laughing about it and
he's just having fun with it so I mean
now that UFC could play it off as a
promotional thing now because you know
they're gonna play it to him it could be
about the fighting they're gonna play
that bus tent the whole time as
promoting it so I mean and that in the
long run is gonna make them money but on
it I'm like a personal thing I think
makes them look bad mm-hmm even if you
don't want their responsibility by being
in the spotlight you obviously have
people like what you said you know young
kids you know kids are gonna be looking
at you and they're gonna end up you know
throwing a tantrum throwing you know
whatever comes whatever it's accessible
hurt maybe here he could have killed
somebody you know I mean yeah exactly
Dali goes to her window and it it could
hit him in the head or I mean it caught
one of them but and the other guy had a
glass go in his eye so that could have
seemed blind to them or really put them
out like I don't think like his first
thing when I thought thought thought
about I first thought it was like a
stunt and the UFC was like just playing
it off but then when I saw guys get hurt
off it I feel like it just went too far
I feel like he probably had the idea
where I'm gonna go out there
just makes it make a little noise get a
little attention off of it but then he
just papi you just went nuts on there
just started throwing stuff throwing the
wrong things I get a trash can at the
thing you know it's not gonna the one
who's not gonna break anything like that
and make you look it'll promoted a
little bit but you're throwing dollies
and uh metal spheres or something
through the window so I'm like that's
how people get hurt
was there any formal apology to this day
that you know of no nothing from kind of
McGregor the the UFC said it and Dana
White said he's talked to Conor McGregor
and like they had their heart-to-heart
whatever and he's apologized to Dane or
anything like that but I haven't seen
anything publicly from Conor yet that's
another thing I mean obviously as human
beings we make mistakes you know and to
be unapologetic and something that you
should be apologizing for that's another
thing that lessons are learned from
people who might do something like that
you're taking this person or anyone else
as an example and they're setting bad
trends and bad examples and now they do
these bad things you do it and they're
not even apologetic so you're not
apologetic and you're just like eh
what's that famous statement he has I
have I'm sorry for absolutely yes how's
that go for absolutely nothing
yeah he said I want to apologize to
everybody for absolutely nothing they're
always like trash-talking he's like
Ronnie's fight Eddie Alvarez he was
talking about his family talking about
everything like that and then I have to
really said I'm sorry for absolutely
nothing so now that's like a big mean
that people always post yeah and then
now you got also guys at UFC now that
are trying to like take after him
because they to see him getting all the
money so what are they doing they're
gonna start talking trash people being
unsportsmanlike and just trying and like
you could tell for Conor kind of good at
it like you could tell he's good Eddie's
practice it but some guys now are just
trying too hard to be that that villain
and uh to beat Kobe Kobe Cummington if
you look at him talking about Brazil
talking about Brazil saying it's a dump
saying the people from there are trash
when he fights a Brazilian guy and then
like you could tell it's fake it's under
percent fake it's just him trying to
play a role as a villain but you're
putting all those people like the
Brazilian fans everybody into like
making them all feel bad making them all
hate you it's gonna make it's gonna make
other kids think I could say the same
thing or I'm a basketball player I'm a
like a ten year old kid and I see him
talking trash about a whole country why
can't I do the same thing about this
other team
or this school like your whole schools
trash anybody from that area's trash so
just gonna make everything look bad and
on yeah and and it goes back to you
having a bigger responsibility and now
you have the spotlight and now people
are you know we're creatures of
imitation and I'm people are imitating
you and the bad things I like what this
cyborg you know cyborg yeah I've seen
her actually wearing hijab I don't know
if you ever seen her yeah sing
masha'Allah you know got a little bit
and and and doing some really she she
actually you know how hobby and and this
is what I kind of went away from from
watching many of the the UFC's and
whatnot but what drew me one time is I
was I was with my cousins and family
where they kept telling me about this
this Muslim UFC guy and then I watched
his fight one time and what really you
know touched me was when he stopped
afterwards and he thanked the Almighty
he thanked the Creator without God we
cannot do nothing everything is nothing
you know number one believe on you wrong
God just I want to say thank you for God
God is number one other things is
nothing it's me you know yeah and he
made such that he went and he prostrated
you know what I mean
I was really impressed with that you
know what I mean and and then we see I
don't know if they did this before and
again it goes back to like people
setting good trends she went out she was
feeding the poor yeah she's not Muslim
she's Christian but that's a good thing
we could we commend that that's what we
need more of you know yeah what do you
what do you that was she was like after
her last fight she went out and I think
she she was that like UFC 200 or
something she went on to give out like
200 meals to kids and the poor people
out there and that's something that the
UFC should be promoting that's the
things that man that's a beautiful thing
that she's going out there she's
promoting that and like you said it
could be every single fight giving us
thanks to giving us time the left for
everything and then even after his title
fight it's not me it's it's from God
that's what that's what it right after
his title fight that's what he's gonna
Mike and I think that's gonna be huge
that we got our first Muslim champion
because it's going to show it's gonna
put us in the limelight
more and it's gonna show like how
Muslims are humble and like from when
you right now when you look at the news
or anything like that they're always
showing
shining the light on all the negative
things that happen to Muslims or guys
that say they're Muslims and they're
terrorists and they're all of this and
all that so now shine the light on a
great Muslim a great humble Muslim
that's a champion that's a real champion
and he's still humble and still not
changing like kind of McGregor we're
Conor McGregor got his money now and
he's becoming that that villain now he
doesn't care what people think of him or
its had that attitude like I'm gonna do
me no matter what I don't care if I have
kids looking up to me I don't care if I
I just had a kid I don't care about any
of that now I'm I'm still the moneymaker
and I'm still gonna be the businessman I
want to be mm-hmm
could be more of a Muslim before he's a
Muslim before a businessman yeah that's
and many people don't know it's you know
and this is the unique thing about our
show we usually because people when they
can't identify with something it's kind
of like the other but once we like
Muslims simply one who is children to
submit to the crater that's it some
people submit to money some people
submit to themselves you know and their
desires but Muslim is one who simply
submits to the creator of all things and
as so we're humbly trying to do and tell
me do you get some bullying yourself now
I mean some people might not know almost
Eddie you know what I mean and it's not
in the name you know what I mean it's
like you got Muslim can mean it can be
named Mohammed can be named Mike you
know it's it's someone a Muslim can be
from an Italy from from Japan from all
over you know to me so that's one
misconception many people have do you
think Muslims are Arabs
you know they mean but Muslims are you
know from all walks of life
do you now because you have the name
Muhammad right but now yeah do you get
some people trying to bully you like
social media social media it's not yeah
obviously not person you know the
keyboard tough guy yeah you know yeah
you always key board tough guys that are
always right right when I post like a
poster or something like that of my next
coming to fight and I'd be like who's a
terrorist how does that tell you like a
terrorist in a cyber bullying yeah
UFC letting a terrorist in the UFC I'm
like what the heck but it's funny then
you have like guys that are randomly
like make weird posts cuz up my sister
she's uh she works with a fun fundraiser
in Chicago it's called PCRF like
Palestinian Children's Relief Fund in
Palestine and then like I'll post
something about that and then some guy
made like a whole article about how that
that fund is like promoting and helping
to
and uh Palestine and Gaza and I'm like
we're like where do people used to come
up with these stories but they just
waste their time to come up with a whole
story shining a negative light on
Muslims trying to do good yeah let's go
you mentioned Gaza many people I was
very surprised that the mainstream media
you know a lot of times they don't give
much attention do and they recently
there was a really good summer awareness
created that we're gonna go into this
clip and then we'll take it from there
see what you think
yesterday President Trump an Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu had a
phone call and according to a White
House readout that they put out
afterwards apparently the two did not
talk about what was probably the most
important thing for them to talk about
and that's the fact that just a few days
ago Israeli troops shot more than 750
Palestinians killing at least 15 yes
that is the correct number more than 750
Palestinians shot at least 15 dead now
this happened at a large protest along
the Gaza border on Friday where as many
as 30,000 people gathered to begin what
was planned as a six-week sit-in
protesting Israel's blockade of Gaza and
supporting Palestinian so-called right
of return to Israel a right that I
should note the Israeli government says
doesn't exist and if enforced would
spell the end of the Jewish state now
defenders of the Israeli military's
actions will point out the protest was
endorsed by Hamas which rules Gaza and a
thuggish and anti-democratic manner and
which uses violence and terror in its
campaign against Israel it will also
note that at this particular protest
there were some protesters who threw
rocks and Molotov cocktails and rolled
burning tires at the border fence all of
which is true but in no way justifies
what Israeli soldiers appear to have
done which is perch on a hill and pick
off protesters with sniper fire much of
it recorded for all to see like for
instance this video which shows live
shots being fired at a teenager as he
runs through an empty area to retrieve a
tire or the shooting of this young man
as he prayed near the border fence as
far as we can tell from the video
evidence I
the F troops in sniper positions rained
down bullets people again and again and
again and not only did the President of
the United States react by saying
nothing not only have the vast majority
of members of Congress what are your
thoughts your from this is where your
family's from a lot of time you don't
get much media press like this the
majority world is ignorant to what's
really going on the oppression you know
it's one of the they say the largest
open air prisons in the world you know
the Gaza what do you I mean honestly I
mean it's heartbreaking when you see
that when you see what's going on down
there and you see them well I've seen
videos where you see Israeli snipers
like laughing as if they're shooting
guys just running it's like a game to
them where they're just seeing kids
running and I just want to shoot them as
a game like four points or something
like that and we see something like a
are people are just protesting but it's
their land and they're getting held into
a little section where they can't move
they can't go anywhere like my sister
went down there uh she just went down
there last month for a Palestinian
marathon and now she said we literally
had to go through about ten checkpoints
just to get to ten ten checkpoint just
get to my grandmother's house and we
were so good we're gonna stop to Avery
every checkpoint getting checked for
everything
asked what are we doing here s why are
we here and she's also because they want
as a picture of group and now some
people had to get sent back from the
airport they get some day to the USA
just because their social media they
posted anything that like show them
protesting Israel or anything like that
it's like my sister literally had to
delete Otto Berg all of her accounts
before she went down there so it they're
just trying to make it hard for like
Americans or other Palestinians that
want to go back to see their home they
wanna they want to make it where
American pet passing the Americans don't
want to go back home cuz it's so hard oh
man I got a I had a status checkpoint
for like an hour or two hours or I'm
stuck at the airport it's not one is ten
yeah well I meant the airport at the
airport yeah she was stuck at the
airport for three hours just to get out
of the airport and then said every tree
checkpoint you're gonna stop that to
you're staying here for like thirty
minutes I'm like that just get checked
so they're making where if I'm an
American I'm a bit lamb what am I gonna
go down there for man they're making so
hard for me to see my own land for me to
see my own family that's down their
grandmother or anything down there
and they're just making us hate to go
down there cuz absolutely want they want
they want
the Palestinians leave and I wanted to
have all the line for himself mm-hmm
many people they also use this this
opportunity to create a division and to
try to promote that Islam Muslims hate
Jews and whatnot but this is a Zionist
agenda this is there's a difference
between Zionism and then you know many
Jews I've had like rabbi Weiss some of
the chief even the chief rabbi a
Palestine at that time he was sending
letters to the UN because he was showing
how the Muslims and Jews they were
living together in peace their children
were go Muslims are watching their kids
you know so now you have even I've had
like Nikko pilet he wrote a book called
the general son he's an Israeli Jewish
and he's speaking on behalf of the the
Palestinian people this is just open
oppression any American that goes down
there and goes and looks and sees from
themselves this is something that the
world doesn't really know because of
many much of the false propaganda you
know what I mean and that's why this was
really good report this is something
that's going on just recently 750 shot
these are unarmed civilians it's sad you
know so these are you know this is good
like people like yourself were down
there creating awareness about this so
you know the average American good
people they don't want to say they don't
want to be sending their 3 plus billion
a year to go killing innocent kids
yeah that's correct like you said it's
crazy like the average American doesn't
know what's going on down there so like
when I saw I actually saw this article
it was a under on his video and I posted
the last week on my like Facebook and
then I went back to practice whatever
and I had like Anthony and Sergio Pettis
do big-time athletes and they're asking
no way is that really going down I'm
like yeah no nobody knows like people
people don't understand what those
people are going through down there man
it's it's hard for them to kids can't go
out there and play it on their kids they
don't have a normal life down there
there's always explosions always bombs
going off it's kids are waking up every
day thinking am I gonna live today or am
I gonna die today it's not I need to go
to school or I'm gonna have friends let
friends like normal like normal kids
should be having fun today or I'm gonna
go to the park sitting in plays man uh
let's go protest day and maybe we'll die
maybe we won't die that's that's what
that's how they're waking up every day
down there what's the food in the water
situation also yeah exactly like I'm
also working on another
a project down here it's called a pious
project with FEMA iref he just posted
that he's uh he's sending like litres of
water down there and stuff like that so
hopefully we'll get a lot of people
donating today as well because I heard
that when you go down there on one side
you have the illegal settlements that
you had like for instance I want people
to imagine you got your home that your
parents and your great-grandparents
passed down and someone just comes and
knocks on the door and says you got to
get out this is what's happening it's
illegal settlements that the UN has
condemned United Nations has condemned
and now for that side you have now water
fresh water you know electricity things
we take for granted and on the other
side of the Palestinians and this is not
just Muslim these are also Christians
who are being oppressed to are
Palestinians that right yeah yeah yeah
like I just saw an article other days
where they said at the protest dude
there's Christians as Muslims and all
the guys uh my grandfather he just
passed away uh probably like eight nine
years ago I let him up and then uh my
sister went down there so for the for
the whole land lease and she said she
went on her to go see what's going on
with this land how it's gonna pass down
to his kids and then the government said
well here goes here goes the money for
it we took the land and it was like kind
of like three thousand dollars for a
huge piece of land that should be going
for big money or anything like that and
they just gave him I said we took the
land this is what you guys get we're not
it's not like a negotiation where you
get to sell it or anything like that
they literally took his land and they
said this is the money for the that get
passed on to the kids instead of my my
grandfather we had a plan where it's
it's gonna be huge where he gonna build
condos for his kids to live on there and
for them to move their families down
there to their homeland but it got taken
away from him money when he passed away
you know this is very very sad and
people compared to South Africa the
apartheid state of South Africa and the
same thing here the open-air prison
meaning that you have a wall wall how
big have you seen that wall yeah I've
seen as you see how huge is that wall
yeah it's big it's big so it's like they
are trapped they can't even leave right
the trapped inside the water you know
the basic things that we take for
granted they don't have you know the
Palestinians are the most most oppressed
well but they're still in there you know
what I mean it shows their commitment to
God their commitment to you know family
and they're not giving up house their
spirit the spirits are strong and this
is what I think is driving many of the
Zionist forces again Muslims we don't
hate their Jews we don't
I mean Jews Muslims and Christians you
know at the pinnacle the golden ages of
Islam in Spain you know I mean these are
golden years for Jews you have a
professor doctor doctor I believe it's a
Hornstein he said he writes in it's
called the JC Journal in a how Islam
saved the jury you know I mean how Islam
saved the Jewish people when they were
you know being persecuted and the
Crusades and the Inquisition they were
being persecuted they came into Muslim
lands and the Muslims welcomed them same
thing in Palestine they were welcomed
but now you have even people who have
been Holocaust survivors who also
condemned what's going on to the
Palestinian people Muhammad Ali he was
also a strong supporter he meant Nelson
Mandela yeah it was huge like you said
where people nowadays assume that you
hate Jews like I have people comment to
my thing all the UFC signed the Jewish
fighter are you gonna fight him and I'm
sitting there like no he's not even my
weight class and they're like okay but
you probably hate him though right and
I'm like no I don't hate like you said I
don't hate Jews it's not there's many
great Jewish people out there that then
this whole situation you Jewish people
opposed the occupation of Palestine from
the very beginning it was in the
nineteen thirties before the creation of
the State of Israel when the politics
began when the Zionists came into the
region rabbi Zalman Feldon at a time
wrote an article in one of the Arabic
newspapers it was called peace and truth
in which he wrote he won't stick he was
the chief rabbi of Palestine clarifying
that the Jewish people have no demand
over any place holy and sacred by the
Muslims
in 1947 a year before the creation of
the State of Israel revolution he the
chief rabbi of Palestine at that time
wrote a written testimony to the United
Nations meeting in Jerusalem and I quote
we furthermore wish to express our
definite opposition our definite
opposition to any Jewish state to a
Jewish state in any part of Palestine he
was ignored by the United Nations at the
time travel yet several months later now
by the schinske sent a telegram to the
United Nations and like success at least
leave Jerusalem and that request was
respected this was how Jerusalem was
kept for taking Jewish leaders the
Jewish communities worldwide opposed the
creation of this state and still do the
philosophy of Zionism is not only
causing a catastrophe for the
Palestinian people it is a true disaster
Jewish people as well it's two people
that are supporting like the Zionism
that's that's what it's all about
nobody know it like the Jewish religion
areas like that it's all closer
everybody's all these religions are
close together and I'll believe like
similar things it's not like I'm gonna
hate you could your Christian I'm gonna
hate you could you're Jewish I don't
have a hatred for our religion I have a
hatred for for heat so like design is
people they hate Palestinian they hate
Gaza they hate Palestine I hate
Palestinian Muslims that's that's a
that's a hatred it's not a religion yeah
this is more of a nationalistic movement
many of them don't even believe in in in
in the Almighty in God you know and
that's why you have many good Jewish
people stepping up and speaking against
Zionism and the occupying force there
and may God Almighty help to bring peace
to the suffering there and sure we can
create some
more awareness and some some good can
come from the little contribution that
we make to to talk about some of the
things where people are scared to kind
of talk about let's go into Bulow
Muhammad Bulow some of his yours top
tweets how's that oh yes get your
comments on that okay all right let's
start with number one so this is uh this
is something that you retweeted actually
but will say your top some of your top
tweets and we'll discuss it I think is
very important it's from and this shows
you know staying connected to scholars
staying connected to people of knowledge
where you're probably like let's see
what secret our multi make we spent so
much and invest even more in order to
project the best image of ourselves to
the world yet on the inside many are
crumbling and falling apart
isn't it time to invest wisely and pay
heed to what lies beneath when you
posted this when you what would you when
you hear this what what do you what do
you take from this what is it I mean it
seems like I love all on him you post
like the powerful stuff and like you
said like most people are sitting there
trying to look good for the for the
outside world mostly but in an era I
need the fanciest clothes fancies cars
the biggest houses nobody's really
exercising like their soul like you got
a like you like I told I just had
interview the other day where people are
like how are you how are you gonna fast
and train during Ramadan cuz I have a
fight during that time and I said most
of these guys are out here looking for
an edge but they're all looking for an
edge with steroids or anything like that
but I'm looking for an edge spiritually
mentally and that's how I get it the
religion of power and stuff like that so
most these people are trying to exercise
and get look good for the outside world
man but if you're spiritually strong and
mentally strong you don't need anything
else
mm-hmm what what did you what did you
think about when they had so this is
very this is very powerful what you said
it's like focusing and you get to see
that you know many people you can take
Conor McGregor we got I got we got
nothing against Conor McGregor or
anybody just using some of the actions
that people do as an example right yeah
we want the best for everybody but when
people are focused more on the cars and
the glitz and the glamour
this is talking about focusing on the
heart what that what's within because
that's where true richness lies and
there's actually a high D for the
promise awesome so true richness comes
in you know contentment in the heart do
you know what I mean someone can have
all the money all the fame but there's
still you know so depressed they're
empty because the heart yes you can see
like you could see mostly like big-time
actors or even the rock he talked about
depression just recently talk about the
present yeah most people are looking at
him like how is rock depressed he's he's
huge has the biggest movies in the world
I'm pretty sure he's super rich has
anybody anything he wants get anything
you want
but if you're not there it's not in your
heart if your hearts not consent if your
hearts not happy if you're not
spiritually like just spiritually I have
a spiritual wellness view then nothing
none of that matters like none of that
outside stuff matters none of the
materialistic stuff matters like you
could be the richest guy in the world
but if you don't have a family that
loves you and just uh connection with
God what's the point of life at what
point in your life did you see yourself
going more towards that connection with
your creator with God with Allah had
that I've been uh I started young when I
was 13 and uh like I had just had a I
just got connected with it you know when
you're your parents or somebody like my
parents weren't the type to force me to
pray or they wanted me to pick up the
religion but it wasn't like a force yeah
where handle I was able to read the
Quran myself and and I just connected
with it when I once I read it and it
just got me the whole time my whole life
since then I just been spiritually
connected within hundred that I feel
like I do have a connection with God and
I feel like whenever I am in trouble or
anything like that I just think about
that go back to Quran and read just
different pseudos or anything like that
and it'll just calm me down mm-hmm many
people they get blown away when we
mention a lot of the commonalities with
our Christian and other counterparts you
know because we're all in this world
together you know I mean so we're
brothers and sisters and humanity we
usually say when we for our Christian
brothers and sisters in humanity when we
talk about you know the deep love and
reverence
we as Muslims have for Jesus peace be
upon him obviously we don't believe him
in as God Almighty because he prayed
like Muslims pray he greeted like
Muslims greet he walked to earth and he
called people to worship God and we were
that God that Jesus called people to
worship but when we see that and many
people don't know that that we love
Jesus you can't be a Muslim unless you
love and believe in him as a mighty
Messenger of God did your when you share
that do people get blown yeah yeah
actually now from my gym uh and
Wisconsin I have guys asking about
what's going on because say I'll being
practicing right now I stopped and I'll
go subtly in the back man I just feel
like a piece of trash that I'm looking
at him pray and I'm just sitting there
yeah like they'll be and they'll ask me
like so like what do you think is like
do you think what when we have uh we say
Jesus God like what do you think like do
we still believe in Jesus he's one of
our prophets he's not like I'm like we
believe in Jesus we have a love of Jesus
but he's not God so there's a big
difference in their know they'll be
super surprised and a bit like oh you
guys believe in Jesus so yeah so you
guys do have Jesus in your Quran and I'm
like yeah yeah it's it's all part of
their man but it's it's not God though
and then so it's just interesting when I
when I have guys ask me about that and
then they interest them and I also have
a couple guys now they're when I
actually start fasting during Ramadan
yeah they're gonna try a couple days a
couple weeks Sergio Pettis where you say
that I'm uh I'm gonna try to fashion
right now with you yeah tell us who's
who's Sergio pennis I know that's he's
another big name in the you yeah exactly
a number fifth ranked flyweight yeah in
the UFC wasn't he supposed to he was
supposed to match up with Habib right no
no Anthony Pettis was supposed to I
suppose could be they're not that's not
the same they're brothers they're
brothers yeah they're both in the both
in the UFC Anthony's the former champion
and surgeries younger brother okay based
on his way to a title fight now yeah but
he's fighting in Chicago in June and
he's talking about yeah trying trash
yeah he's that he's the one that I said
that where like he'll come over our
house our apartment I know like play
video games whatever and then I'll go
pray and then he'll say Amen just seeing
you pray man I just feel like I feel
like I need to start picking up things
with with God and just getting connected
spiritually it's like I think I'm
starting with you guys here man like how
do you guys do it and all this stuff and
he said I'm gonna start doing them I try
to do anything so see that's beautiful
that's beautiful when you take a timeout
I mean we got sponsors right in UFC
Reebok now you can't there's there's no
other sponsor that you can thank now in
there right usually you think you're
probably your trainers and all that yeah
but when we stop I mean
the world to know we stopped because you
couldn't throw a punch if your nerve
goes out like I got some like now you
know my nerves give me a little problem
so I feel can't even do you know too
many pushups got a little injury and
like wow just if a nerve goes out right
now or maybe you know a nerve in the
tube you ever have like a tooth yeah
yeah yeah God has given us the Almighty
has given us all these blessings so we
stop because without him we wouldn't be
able to do any of this stuff we wouldn't
able to walk throw a punch you know talk
speak taste the food the taste buds that
we have all of these are blessings and
many people they don't they don't think
about you know what I mean they don't
think about so when you stop is
beautiful you stop and you go you know
take the highest part of man to take it
to the lowest part and to humble
yourself and that keeps us humble right
and to connect with the one who gave us
life the owner of life the creator of
the heavens on earth that's a beautiful
thing and people that's the fifth a time
when people see you praying let that
happens that's like a form of dollar
that's a form of like wow that's just
connects people like I want to do that
yeah yeah yeah they man they were like
man I wanna just have that relationship
with God I want to do wanna just get out
get to that level of where I could be
that spiritually strong or it might
strong and it'll be like where I'll sit
there and train during Ramadan not
drinking i eating stuff like that and
nobody how could you do it how could you
do that but you I think I got on my side
man nothing's gonna happen to me that
way or anything like that so I just is
just shocked so when I see this type of
thing and this is exactly what Muhammad
Ali said also you know I played a clip
for when I had Miss Arabic ditch I
played a clip where Muhammad Ali he was
talking about how the training got to
his head where he thought it was his
training camp and everything and then he
got his jaw broke I think it was by
Frazier someone yeah and that kind of
humbled him and and then he said he
really started to make his prayers he
started to connect more with the law
with God and then he said he felt
unstoppable I didn't do that for the
first phrase to fight novice at first
Norton fight really no sir
our head got big and I started thinking
it was my training camp and my boxing
ability they kept me where I was that
and God punished me and he gave me a
good whoopin he broke my jaw in the
sacrum fight and he got me whooped and
knocked down in the Frazier fight and I
realized I wasn't that great after all
so I had to get not only together
physically but spiritual
for this fight I've trained every day
for five days five times a day for the
past of four months and everything is
perfect and if I lost with me it ain't
no way no man can win no way man I feel
like that somebody can definitely relate
to and this is this is something that
many people connect with you know that's
why Islam is like we say it's the
natural way it's like you're connecting
only with the Creator a direct dial up
no body in the middle no intercessor
just God just the one who created you
the same God that Jesus Moses Abraham
and Mohammed that peace be upon just
allows the final messenger so it's a
unique beautiful way of life and that's
wonderful when people like yourself now
they are looking at you you they are
like a maze like what's he doing him out
of all people he's stopping that's why
you carry you know a great
responsibility people like yourself and
on some of the other guys and I want to
encourage that guys continue to you know
to do those little things that can make
a great impact yeah I got like not
forget exactly you know you don't sit
there and think that people are watching
on that way but then I'll get like
messages from young kids on social media
like that saying that your your agree or
role model to us and all this stuff and
I'm thinking like man who am i all might
be a role model to all these kids and
then you think you realize that you're
on that platform where you could speak
for the people they can't speak for
themselves
so that's why I want to sit out there
and go out there and support Palestine
still carry my flag with me no matter
where I go on TV and pay-per-view or
anything like then I get to that level
inshallah and carry a belt and the flag
at the same time mm-hmm
what do you think there's there's a
there was that attack a Muslim day was
that what it was yeah what'd you think
when you saw something like that yeah
man I thought it was crazy I said yeah I
said people are really gonna pick this
up and are people really gonna do this
type of [ __ ] thing and I was like I
don't even get a bit give it a tension
but then when you got your parents and
your mom that wears the hijab and you're
like you start getting scare like maybe
what if somebody like a some crazy guy
does do something stupid or try to pull
out the eye jab or do something crazy
like that but then you think you just
hope and uh there was I think there was
a girl who got attacked and like a
hospital
I'm at the hospital incident right yes
four people died don't know what we're
talking about let's let's go ahead and
let them see exactly because seeing is
believing
did you see so the guy he just she's
wearing hijab he just walks up she was
like about nineteen years old at the
hospital place were you supposed to
think you're safe yeah this is real I
mean it's it's really that's why we we
talk about being unapologetically Muslim
is to show that hey we're Muslim we're
out there were your neighbors were your
friends colleagues you know doctors
engineers people who train with you and
that we're open come talk with us you
know ii mean not like we're a better
than anybody but at the time where
people are like changing their their
stats scared they're changing their they
don't want even be called muhammad they
call them old you know i mean they're
scared to be muslim and then that that
helps that Islamophobia that helps that
to grow and then just our voices get
shut down even further exactly like you
see then then you think about your mom
or something like that you're hoping
that people who are like that guy that
they're who stopped the guy from from
attacking her and then you wonder man
what if she was at her car outside in a
parking lot or something like that yeah
there was nobody around how far would
that guy have gone to beat her up or
take it take it even to the next level
and maybe even kill her you don't know
what's gonna be around or what's gonna
happen but then but then you have your
mom that's tough and like oh it's a gam
what some day I'm still gonna go to the
mall I don't care but uh just to have
that attitude so it's funny when he's
like you said we're people gonna be on
apologetically Muslim they're still
gonna go out and still not let this
thing bother them and not make them
afraid and keep them indoors or keep
them away from other people there was
also a another incident I mean use a lot
of these these are just some of the ones
were pointing out it was a Muslim woman
who was who was stabbed by her attacker
and there was a five thousand dollar
reward being offered to help catch the
attack their attacker who attacked a
Houston Muslim woman during a
hate-filled attack the driver reportedly
got out of his SUV get this and he began
shouting obscenities and racial and
religious slurs such as oh my god it's a
rag head and calling the n-word sand and
you know after that and other derogatory
nerve terms against Muslim and he ended
up
stabbing the woman it seems like these
guys these you know tough guys they end
up you know preying on the weak and
innocent yeah that's what it always is
like like I said I said uh if this guy
would attacked a man that he thought was
a Muslim or anything like that they
wouldn't have gone that way so they're
gonna go on these these girls or girls
that are wearing a jab and that's just
that's like the highlight but you know
how you know there are Muslim so they're
gonna attack the girls at I have an idea
that's why it's gonna it's it shows how
strong our woman are that there's still
no matter what they're still gonna keep
it on it's not gonna stop them from
wearing hijab or going out into the
public or anything like that is still
gonna go to her work with the head jab
on so it just shows how powerful our
woman can be let's get into a one more
example because many people there's that
false notion that you know the double
standards in the media and those there's
good people always out there who call
out some of these things and it's one
thing it comes from us but then it's
another thing when it comes out from
people like this I want you to get your
comments on this another high school
shooting yesterday this was in Florida
seventeen dead the last report I saw and
everybody sends their thoughts and
prayers again because that works so well
this is the 18th high school shooting in
America this year and we have ten and a
half months to go we've had 290 since
2013 we average about one a week but
there's just nothing we can do if it was
a Muslim or a Mexican doing the shooting
how many new laws and how much money
would we spend then to stop the madness
but since it's almost always a white kid
there's just nothing we can do it seems
like it goes back to the when we started
off with the incident like painting the
picture you on a plane
Mohammed it would have been connected to
Islam this is Islam he's doing a jihad
he's coming you know to terrorize the
u.s. see now he's a sleeper cell right
and usually you see like many of these
mass shootings these criminal terrorist
attacks that are happening on a daily
basis so they get very little press
coverage right then some lunatic right
he goes a fringe element goes and does
something and all of a sudden you know
Islam is equated the guys doing totally
opposite he could have been someone
who's drinking fornicate doing all sorts
of evil OPSEU Aslam and now they used
the worst example and they
connected back to Islam you see a lot of
these things happening yeah exactly like
I said anything bad happen is then
they're gonna shine a light on the the
Muslim aspect of it right away but where
like the school shooting or even the
Vegas shooting with a guy was shooting
out of the room in the concert and I'm
saying they're like how many people got
killed in that and they didn't say it
was a terrorist act yeah or they never
bring it up they said the guy was
mentally ill or his wife said he was
depressed clinically depressed and I'm
sitting there like why are these guys
clinically depressed but the Muslims
Arabian guy that did it because I don't
consider the Muslims the guy that do
those crazy acts or kill innocent people
they're not Muslims but they'll say
they'll bring it slam right into it I
heard him say a long walk but that's
like that would be like the headline or
this guy all clinically depressed or a
kid that was a loner or people that
nobody could nobody talk to the kid he
was bullied so that's what forced him to
kill all these innocent kids or kill all
the minutes of people at that concert
when the guy you could tell the guy they
said the guy wasn't millionaire like you
said the guy who did that Vegas
shootings he was a millionaire he had
money so there's really nothing in there
but he said if he's not spiritually
connected to anything so we went out
there and killed all the people for no
reason but they don't they don't bring
that part up they say always wife says
all he was depressed that's dead what
that was a reason for it and I and I
think it's important we bring these
things up so you know good people good
hearted people the people who are who
that that hate is just is just
penetrated their heart and no matter
what you do say a lot of times that just
you know it's just manifesting itself
from what's in the heart usually these
people are bitter angry and they're just
looking for somebody to you know a
scapegoat that anger but genuine people
when this these double standards people
like this are saying get many more news
reporters they're seeing it like what we
had shown what's going on in Gaza I'm
surprised it's got the aired yeah right
so they're they're starting to see the
hypocrisy you follow me and they're
being more sympathetic because they're
seeing how Muslims are being maligned
how the discrimination how the
Islamophobia is spreading it's a big
industry it's like you know if you want
to make money you just start bashing
Islam and Muslims and you're going to
get paid but it's important we speak up
we'd be unapologetically Muslim to show
people that we're here make the human
connection with us and not go to some of
these these people are just trying to
divide us you know I mean so I want to I
want to ask you a couple more
I like my friend do you like I like Joe
Joe Joe what do you think we got in
common
Oh what's he wearing what's up we're
sure it's the same shirt he's got much
that's not Photoshop you know I really
liked you I don't know if you watch some
of the previous shows that we've done
we've had some some scholars on Joe
covers a lot of good topics and I wanted
to bring this up with you because
obviously you probably listen to Joe
here and there yeah I don't know if you
got to see the programs that we did we
brought on some Muslim scholars we
academically we didn't bash Joe we
didn't put we just went and it's one
thing criticizing that's fine but there
seems to he's made some deliberate
attempts to talk about Islam and Muslims
in a negative light
for instance saying that Islam oppresses
women Islam promotes violence against
women yeah it is it's very in in terms
of like its suppression of women's
rights and does Islam a pressure your
mother your mom wears hijab yes
is she oppressed know what would she say
right now if you asked her she was Joe
Rogan and and Mohammed's Bulow and she's
coming like chant a champion of women's
rights and he's saying that eight come
on take the hijab off you you're being
oppressed here in America what would she
say to him or your sisters your sisters
where he just seriously would lash you
think it's crazy ugh you said heavens at
the feet of your mom so you got a tutor
mom that at that level your mom's the
highest queen in your house no matter
what so I that's crazy al you would even
think that or say something like that
yeah he talks about acid in the face
Muslim country but even in these
countries these Islamic countries that
are throwing acid in the face
she suffered third-degree burns when her
ex-boyfriend hired another man to throw
acid in her face these people that
practice the Islamic religion to have
Ali from the boys he would normally
[Music]
those are the words David Phillips we'll
get on to him in just a moment these
Islamic countries pay the attack
happened in daylight in downtown
Vancouver Washington
I am Islamophobic said it it's true but
if it's some Imam who thinks that you
know women should cover themselves up
like they look like Jabba the Hutt or
what is it was it boba fett whichever
one whatever it is please direct your
hate mail to Jo Rove if you know assasin
her disaster deface like Islam promotes
you know and he shows these examples and
trying to connect so the average person
that's a scary thing it makes it seem it
feeds into this llama phobia like Islam
and is promoting violence is promoting
the oppression of women so now these
nutjobs out there they get this because
he's out the one of the biggest
followings out there so they hear this
stuff and this I mean it's obviously
fuels the division Oh even more in the
misunderstanding and the hate and and
then you have boss a mosque being
vandalized women being attacked and all
these things so we're trying to reach
out to and we we academically we refuted
many of the the the false statements
that he had made honor killings there's
no honor in killings this is another one
what do you have to say about that
you're not a scholar or anything but
when you hear this is just you know the
regular practicing Muslim when you hear
him say stuff like that what goes to
your mind it's nuts like you said the
slamming and generally means peace so
like when he says when people think that
or we kill because it's in our religion
or we we oppressor our fans are our
wives our mothers or anything like that
they're just nuts because it gives
people like a false notion and false why
should you guys forced her to wear that
ya know they they choose to wear that
yeah my sister chose to wear that idea
when she was 15 years old she chose like
I said my parents aren't going to force
us to do anything she she would read the
Quran she she believed in it and it she
did herself that's it's a responsibility
if she wants to do it as herself we're
not gonna force anything on it and then
but like they'll see like cultural
things or you see like Saudi Arabia that
old woman can't drive it like that it
has nothing to with religion that's
that's just a recover we actually
covered that also we currently that dad
MIFF he brings up go ahead yeah it's in
that area it's not like no women around
the world are able to almost a Mormon or
able to drive or get jobs or anything
like that my sister's a pharmacist so
she graduated school and it has nothing
to do with us forcing her or her not
being able to do anything she did on her
own yeah beautiful so if you had a
chance to you see Joey at the you
three thousand at the fights yeah yeah
tell him I give him our piece which tell
me synonyms hellos from us and we'd like
to hopefully I'm sure this has gotten to
him because we've done a few of them we
actually had Muhammad he jab
you know Muhammad hijab yeah yeah yeah
we had him also and we invited him to
invite him to invite any of it we have
access to some of the top scholars in
the world okay we don't have to go
outside of America we got them here yeah
well I think that would be fair and
balanced that if he brings on a Muslim a
scholar and academic and let's go I
think the audience would love this yeah
that would not be huge yeah he gets so
many more Muslims to come in and also
his audience probably want to know
what's up with this why let's that's in
essence of keeping it fair and balanced
yeah bring up these things and let's go
ahead let's talk and these that type of
guy I think I feel like he would be the
be the one to what want do that debate
or bring it on yeah yeah so what I mean
instead of bringing all of these people
you know he had someone on there let me
just show you one thing radical Islam
gets thrown around right so radical
Islam simply means I really take my
Islam seriously and now this person who
he brings on frequently and pretty much
says it pretty much if you practice
Islam that's what it translates to you
know you're pretty much erratic these
are I mean this stuff is dangerous okay
so do you take your Islam seriously yes
so that would equate that your radicals
yeah so those are kind of you know the
the things that are very laughable it
just doesn't make sense that someone
would I mean I like Joe I really I don't
like heaven II hate I don't like the
actions that he's doing towards you know
something that yourself me and one point
seven eight billion people in the world
you know love and practice and
intellectuals who have come to Islam not
just blindly they have investigated
they've seen that the Quran is a book
from the Creator it cannot be its tamper
free tamper-proof it has all the
evidence and size that is indeed from
the Creator and it's just it's you know
the Harvard University has an ayah from
the Quran talking about for their law
academic Academy these are the most
intellectual lawyers that they're
producing talking about the the ayah the
verse on justice
did you know about that nod that's
profound you know what I mean yeah yeah
so obviously there's this gap that needs
to be bridge and I thought I wanted to
get your thoughts on that
yeah you could send them our hellos when
you see her yeah yeah sure but like you
said even my like my last fight was last
July and it was right after the Milan
but it just brought attention to his
head to when he was like because he
compensated it and he was like well him
and this guy trained during Ramadan for
the so his whole camp but it just rings
like attention to it to the public like
now people what's Ramadan or anything
like that or Google though they'll see
what it is but like you said if we get
on that show that'd be amazing
yeah yeah I want to thank you thank you
for coming on the Deen show doctor say
yeah Allah bless you the Creator bless
you thank you very much your honor you
wanna shout out to anybody anything
not just thank you for everybody uh who
supports me and uh where most of them
were here and there's nothing to fear
I like that we're Muslim we're here
there's nothing to fear yeah um just
habla thank you my brother thank you so
much